a military leader abdiramanchiani has
also recalled niger's Envoy from
Washington but the U.S Secretary of
State says the Biden Administration will
continue to support efforts by the West
African Bloc Icarus to restore democracy
we believe it is vitally important that
what ecowas has called for actually take
effect and that is the
freeing a president bazoom and a
restoration of the Constitutional order
in Niger and we support the efforts that
ecowas is making including the pressure
that it's exerting in order to achieve
that that result
it's bringing our correspondent Ahmed
Idris he is joining us from Abuja in
neighboring Nigeria and it is the last
day of regional talks in Nigeria to try
and end the crisis act and there's just
so much at stake here not just for Niger
but for ecowas too
exactly two days to the deadline Echoes
gave to the military forces in Asia this
meeting is coming to an end here in
Abuja they've been strategizing on
possible deployment should in case that
became necessary we've seen a flurry of
diplomatic activity over the past few
days as Echoes probably is trying to
find an easy way to resolve this crisis
especially after certain countries have
expressed their support to Nigeria
countries like Mali Burkina Faso and a
few others especially uh in the east and
north of the country now Nigeria is a
landlocked country but basically a lot
of people are thinking that if these
countries come together and impose
sanctions or code on nature of probably
that could put a lot of pressure on
Niger so The Echoes have sent in
delegation also to Libya and Algeria to
try to draw them into the process of
ending this particular conflict
meanwhile Security Forces in Nigeria the
defense headquarters had issued a
statement earlier two days ago saying
that so far there is no specific orders
for the militaries in the region to
deploy or near Nigeria or go into
Nigeria at the moment so what they are
doing they just finish their discussions
and hand over resolutions to the Council
of heads of state and government who
will make a final call on whatever was
necessary and one military presence
that's on its way out of the notably
French soldiers are leaving Niger they
were in the country to fight armed
groups in the region so what impact is
their exit going to have on these years
of efforts to defeat groups that are
linked to isil that are linked to
al-Qaeda in the region
it's going to cause a lot of problems
it's going to create a vacuum but again
a military analysts in the region in
particular talking about French presence
in West Africa in Sahel in their former
colonies Mali has been battling with
Al-Qaeda and other ungroups for a very
long time the French deployed there for
more than a decade and fortunately that
crisis did not end that has generated a
lot of sentiments against the French in
Mali and that has also generated a lot
of anti-frank sentiments in several
other countries in West Africa former
colonies of were French but the
departure of the French will create a
vacuum which probably could see
could sort of um
play right into the hands of iron gurus
operating in the region and probably
also create a vacuum for Wagner to
intervene and apart from that we're also
there are also concerns in the region
that if uh the military authorities in
Nigeria accept the calls of most these
areas to chase out Western powers out of
Niger then probably this will also
affect uh other the presence of other
European countries and the United States
of America if they move out there will
be a huge vacuum and it's doubtful if
the armies of Burkina Faso and Mali and
guinea who have their own problems in
their backyard will be enough to sort of
police a very vast country like uh Niger
that's very doubtful so basically it's
going to create a lot of problems for
Nigeria and for the entire region but
the biggest concern politically for the
region is that in five in three four
five years the West African region or
the Sahel has seen about five six or
even seven schools successful and
attempted ones
and thank you very much for that ah but
address with the latest live in Abuja